if we were gonna disassemble a great
screenplay take it apart and examine it
what would we find
medicinal a great screenplay try to
reverse-engineer it and and construct
our own based on that what you would
find in it is various let's call them
techniques or tools that a screenwriter
has used to keep the audience engaged so
that when you are when the curtain goes
up or you click the button and it says
streaming that that from that moment
there are they're manipulating your mind
your brain using various tools and
techniques so that to keep you going for
a moment a moment and the the the first
book that I did the sequence approach oh
let's see it this this this fine volume
what's actually it sequences are in the
title and it's the how the organizing
principle of the book but I actually
thought sequences are kind of like the
hook to get the reader to learn about
all the other things techniques that you
can use to keep an audience interested
so it's like there hadn't been a book
explicitly about the sequence approach
before this and so I thought well that's
a good angle to use but there's once you
get the concept it's pretty simple to
understand but what goes on in the
sequences and what tools that filmmakers
use the storytellers use to keep you
interested that's fascinating to me too
and so this was a I thought a good way
to get you interested so you can learn
and learn about these other things that
filmmakers do and so specifically the
kinds of things you'll find
let's let's start out at the beginning
what do you do there is a lot of thought
and work out there about three act
structure and the act structure etc etc
and in the very beginning of a movie you
can throw all that out it's not really
about that sort of thing it's really
about it tends to be about human
curiosity hey can you come up with a
puzzle can you come up with some
interesting image or some line of
dialogue or something that is puzzling
this it leaves a gap in our
understanding and makes us wonder what
the answer is and people many times
account the common wisdom was you got a
hook an audience a reader in the first
ten pages of your screenplay okay you
got a hook them by the first ten pages
and I've always felt that there's no
reason why you can't hook them on the
first page all you have to do is raise a
question in the in the readers mind on
the first page and then promise them an
answer on page two okay I'll turn the
page you know implicitly and you know
you'll get an answer and then on page
two if you get the answer but then
there's maybe a couple more questions
raised and then you want to find out and
you keep turning and then once you or
you're in there you're hooked so the
readers hooked so generally you'll see
we'll begin with some kind of puzzle
something that is intrigues us possibly
the main character but not always is
involved in that and then as the answers
come you can get a start to get to know
a person usually the classical
formulation you see oftentimes somebody
struggling to try to get something and
then they get it
we don't really know them yet but we
start to develop a sense of connection
with a character
and that if we're looking at a main
character hooked in the first part of
the pay introduced early in this film
they're not always that way but often
then once you're there then you're going
to see tools well I guess we can talk
about what I identify in the book as the
four main tools that filmmakers use and
that I've observed screenwriters and by
extension filmmakers the use in keeping
an audience engaged and the most obvious
one that you'll see goes by a couple
different names it's I call it
telegraphing which can be a negative
thing in acting and I supposed to
Telegraph your emotions that kind of
thing but it's a different sense of the
term telegraphing or it's also known as
advertising it's also known as in
theatre I've seen it called sign posts
or finger posts it's just simply telling
the audience what is coming a purely
narrative function and the thing to keep
in mind is that drama unlike a novel
drama is about something that hasn't
happened yet so it's particularly
obsessed with the future it's about
what's creating anticipation in the
audience a novel you've got a narrator
the narrator tells you something that
already happened before and you can rely
on the narrator to give you all the
information a play and a movie hasn't
happened yet and that's why you'll see
since the beginning they are a stage
play and a screen play their
instructions and they're written in the
present tense this goes here this goes
there this person does that and then so
that's that's why you have that so that
tense because it's about it's a
description about something the audience
is about to see and how you do that how
the filmmakers or the actors are
supposed to do it so with that in mind
telegraphing is can be something as
simple as a character and what's called
an appointment the character says
I'll meet you at Jerry's dousset area at
five o'clock okay so what does that mean
because film is selective we don't
generally start a camera and just keep
it running for an hour and a half you
cut to different places you like to keep
the audience oriented so if you tell the
audience two characters say I'm seeing
at Jerry's use of Terry at five o'clock
and we'll talk then then when you cut to
Jerry to citerior you don't have to
explain why you're there
you've already anticipated it so a
simple appointment is an example of that
a deadline has more emotional Freight to
it it's like you have a certain number
of hours to get a certain thing done and
so it can put time pressure on a
character but else it also shapes the
overall picture picture to it can it can
be used for that for example there's a
couple of these that have deadlines 500
days of summer comes along okay so it's
gradually counting up it skips around
but you know when you get to 500 yeah
the story is going to be over Julie and
Julia I think it was called okay so what
was that they're gonna do the all the
recipes in the book one a day okay so
when you get 2 recipe 300 guess what you
know the movies probably gonna end
before and pretty soon so you're not
gonna go on another hour or two and then
that helps shape an audience's sense of
where to invest its energy I think we've
all been in a situation where we watch a
movie we think it's over and then it
just keeps going I thought it was done
and then we're sapped of energy and
we're like how long how much longer is
this going on and that just simply means
that the filmmaker has a storyteller
hasn't signaled to the audience properly
when the big moment is and sometimes you
can do that with simple telegraphing the
movie I'm trying to think of an American
Beauty it begins with a voice a
disembodied voice saying and in a year
I'll be dead that's a deadline for you
you know so this is
give us a sense while work on this movie
will take place in over the course of a
year you know that implicitly okay so
that happened at the beginning of that
movie more typically telegraphing has
just used internally to keep us oriented
you have enjoy story the opening it's
well very well crafted movie where you
have the birthday parties coming so you
just have a sign that says birthday
happy birthday so we know what's about
to happen and then there's a reference
to we're moving in a week okay so
there's a deadline this movie will take
place in one week and it helps or let's
go to Pizza Planet these are all
examples within it so now we're going
there and there's another couple scene
between that moment so that's that's one
tool that you will see in the in movies
that manage the tension and keep you
interested in keep you going
that one has purely narrative function
not really emotional one that has more
emotion is talked about this before it's
a term called dangling cause you have
cause and effect and this term applies
to a cause that doesn't have an effect
immediately
it dangles so it's instead of a
character saying instead of a boy likes
girl therefore a boy kisses Garland's
boy likes girl and says I will kiss her
you know before the day is up and then
you'll have a bunch of scenes and but
you're waiting your pushes the audience
attention into the future well is it
going to happen or not so you'll have a
character give a warning to somebody a
warning a threat don't you dare come
back here if I see you here again I'm
going to whatever a prediction an
expression of hope I just hope that that
this is that you know I'll survive today
or something like that
now I'll learn what I need to learn but
a character does that again that is
something that creates anticipation so
you will tend in a well-made movie to
see that sort of technique being used
the thing you don't want to have is
the audience wondering where is this
going I don't know where this is going
or the reader I've read 10 pages I have
no idea what the story is well if you
put these little things in there
embroider the script with these elements
these tools then you're gonna help allay
that problem the next tool that you see
is dramatic irony this is a one where a
character knows the audience knows more
than one or more of the characters and
it has some salient it creates a salient
issue for the scene the character
doesn't know there's somebody behind the
wall wait with a gun to shooting them
you know so what are we worried about
why we in tune with that because attuned
to it because we want to find out what
happens when the character figures it
out this moment of recognition oh my god
or it could be obviously a threat that
creates suspense it could be used for
convict irony to people that are talking
and we don't know that one of them is
sleeping in the other person's bed
without them knowing about it you know
that every scene there's the movie the
shop around the corner which was remade
decades later as you've got male about
two clerks the first one was about two
clerks working in a shop who are each
corresponding to somebody that they
haven't met yet that they are in love
with and they don't realize that it's
actually each other and in person they
can't stand each other so every scene
every scene that has those two in it has
an extra layer of excitement to it and
it leads us to this anticipation what's
gonna happen when they find out the
truth
so that's dramatic irony and then the
fourth tool is the one that gets all the
press and that you'll hear about
relentlessly is this idea of dramatic
tension which is where the three-act
destruction comes in and that's just
character want something we care about
that character and we are in suspense
about whether they're going to get it
and that one you can sustain for a whole
feature film or longer and you'll see it
though in subunits you're asking if you
deconstruct it what are you going to
find in the screenplay well you will
tend to see one unifying tension and the
main tension that one unifying tension
will boy get girl will girl get boy
little girl get girl whatever you know
how you define it that can be enough to
that that creates the the unity in a
movie that makes it feel like one movie
rather than a whole bunch of scenes
stuck together it's like what was that
about well it was about whether the
person would get this okay that's what
it's about but within that within the
subunits you have these dramatic scenes
and dramatic scenes can use the same
structure a dramatic scene will still
have a character who wants something and
there's obstacles and if you you know if
you study acting you'll see that it's
drilled into the actors what's my
objective in the scene what am i trying
to do what is my action it's not about
emotion it's about trying to do
something drama drama comes from the
doing it's doing things it's action so
within each scene once you have a
connection to a character you will see
this same thing happening yes you have a
character who silver linings playbook
the character wants to reconnect with
his ex-wife
okay that's the main question main
tension is he gonna do that or not
then within a scene he may be fighting
with his father about whether he should
you know go out for a run or fix the the
window that he broke right that's a very
different tension but it's so attention
and it's built in within a particular
scene you'll also ten
to see in successful movies what the the
sequences that are they tend to be
invisible to a viewer but to a writer
who is trying to create a movie they're
very useful building blocks and that is
seeing and though seeing a mini movie a
mini story within the bigger one that is
a component of it and those also tend to
have three act structures and it's a
nested structure you have multiple
iterations at different levels you have
at the scene level character once
leavening there's obstacles but the
scenes are in service of a bigger
tension with character has to go through
multiple things to try to get to what
they want within the sequence and then
the sequences themselves are built into
the overall three act structure of a
dramatic piece and and there are issues
about how many acts you have what are
the acts should they be four should
there be none it's it's really about how
you define the acts and whether you're
playing with dramatic tension if you
have if you have a main issue about a
character wanting something and there's
obstacles you have to know who that
character is you have to connect with
them emotionally you have to know what
the obstacles are yep and then once you
know those things properly what's at
stake then the questions would raise the
tension is out there that's your end of
your first act if you don't know those
things you're not going to have any
tension for character wants something if
there's two characters you let's say
you're in a park and you see two people
playing tennis and they're going at it
they're really going at it it's not
necessarily dramatic to you if they're
strangers it's just two people really
going at it and whether one wins of the
other doesn't mean anything but if you
know one of them and you know that
person you love them dearly and you
found out that they bet their entire
fortune on this one game and you also
know that the guy they're playing
against their girl is a hustler who
who's suckered them into it then that
changes
experience of it you are now hanging on
every shot and you're hoping that
somehow they're going to overcome this
and though that information that makes
it traumatic
that's your first act you you can't have
an adramal without that and then the
third act simply refers to the
resolution of that tension because you
if you don't have the third act that
means you you found out that you're
there dearly beloved brother that
everything on this game against the
hustler and it's really intense and then
I got to go and we don't find out who
wins it you could probably do that you
probably people would get a little upset
the audience would feel incomplete so
that's what that three axes so
deconstructing it those are the elements
that that you would find and these are
the pieces that are keeping us involved
from one stage from one moment in the
story to the next but the login
you